[Music]
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi how
are you
better than I deserve what's up that's
good I have a question for you I'm
hoping you can confirm the direction
that I think I need to go in I am
recently widowed my husband passed away
in his 50s and I'm in my 50s also in
2016 16 okay two years ago okay three
that tune it yeah almost three years yes
in 2016 thank you I appreciate that and
we've been able to raise two wonderful
kids right before he passed away we were
in the middle of building our dream home
there was a plan on staying for the rest
of our lives he passed away and I ended
up finishing the project and my kids
moved in with me now they no longer live
with me and I am ready to sell my house
I'm also I'm also in real estate and I
have my house on the market the good
news is is that we have a lot of equity
in the house and I would like to take
the proceeds from the sale of the house
and into something else either a double
or I guess that's really my question you
know what would be your best advice with
what to do with the money that I get
once I go through the active fail so
what would you where would you like to
end up on your seventy and that's a
great question well I'd certainly
I certainly am striving to be debt-free
I have a mortgage right now on this
house so how much will you get out of
this house
when I go to the act of sale I'll
probably be able to take out about 400
maybe a little bit more 400 thousand or
a little bit more and what is house
worth when you're selling it it's worth
in the high eight definitely so if you
move from an $800,000 house to a four
hundred thousand dollar house and paid
cash that'd be a pretty substantial move
down is that something you'd want to do
what I want to do is not be in debt and
I want to be wise and
really ultimately want to leave
something to my children because I know
that's what their father would want if
at all possible that's the last thing on
the list not definite not the first
thing the first thing is for you to be
wise and create a sustainable situation
that you can go forward without huge
amounts of financial stress and be able
to build some wealth the result of that
will be an inheritance to your kids but
we're not going to make the moves we're
gonna make wise moves for you that will
result in wealth that gives you the
ability to leave an inheritance we're
not going to say I got to do this
because of an inheritance ok ok so what
are you making a year selling real
estate well I'm a new realtor so I'm not
making a whole lot yet a whole lot yet
are you really getting beat well yeah I
was going to say I'm getting as as my
husband's cases are settling I'm getting
revenue from that and so for example
last year I probably made from his cases
almost $200,000 and I've got another
option here I don't understand his cases
he was an attorney he was an attorney
and his law firm is honoring his split
on the case settlements the law firm
that we are now associated with has been
honoring that yeah ok good
so I have another couple of years where
that's going to happen mm-hmm right the
because the situation is I don't know I
don't have a guarantee on what's coming
in per year I don't I don't have that
how much money do you have
so I've got about $50,000 on the side
$50,000 in reserve don't you know that
I'm trying very hard not to touch John
how much do you have in retirement
savings that is it that's my retirement
savings about 50,000 whatever you don't
like it's in this house no 401 K from
him no life insurance proceeds from him
that aren't that are available nothing
else we're talking about very minimal
life insurance and that is correct
nothing else that we're talking about
other than the proceeds from his law
practice in the house that I have now I
would buy $400,000 house or
and pay cash for it and I would get your
corner and I'd get your career up and
running before these cases before the
income from these cases run out okay and
if you're making a hundred thousand
dollars a year selling real estate which
I kind of think you can do after talking
to you for a few minutes if you do that
then you know you're 52 53 54 years old
and your only income is your real estate
income and you're making really good
money and you could do that for the
following 20 years and invest and have a
paid-for house and almost no personal
overhead that puts you in a very very
good position okay I'm glad to hear that
I mean so you let's say let's say you
make $100,000 a year and starting at age
55 and you do that page 75 because lots
of people sell real estate up into their
70s and 80s okay not unusual at all
because it's a fun business and they ki
they get in I'm having a lot of fun yeah
you get energy from it so it's not like
I thought it quit my job oh my job you
know it's not that kind of thing so
you're probably going to work for 20
years right and so if you did if you say
fifteen thousand dollars a year for 20
years I mean you're gonna have millions
of dollars in that account okay and that
doesn't count you know the fact that you
can probably do more than that given
that you don't have any personal
overhead we just got rid of your house
payment yeah that's true and we thank
God we don't have any credit card debt
or any card debt nothing nothing like
that thank God
yeah it really might the thing that I
need to get rid of is the house note yep
yep I agree and there's nothing to panic
about you you're okay you got the money
to pay the house note we're not going to
give this house away but I am but I
would take my time and repurchasing
because the money's made it to buy and I
would try to take my 400k cash and get a
steal of a deal somewhere because you
can you could make an offer on Monday
and close on Friday when you're sitting
on cash right right that gives you that
gives you buyer's firepower there's your
power as a buyer and you'll you you know
you'll experience that as you represent
cash buyers later on
- but in other words I think you might
slip up on a half million dollar house
for 400 yeah that would be wonderful and
you and so a couple of people have
advised me that maybe take takes not all
of the money but take most of the money
and put it down and carry a small notes
but you're saying that that's something
that is not your advice nope nope I'd be
dead Frank I'd be dead I like that idea
very much if you can find a house that
it suits your needs in that price range
I'd be dead free and I think yeah and I
think you can the only the only problem
for you is not the four hundred thousand
dollar home in the New Orleans area the
only problem is you've been used to live
in an 800 you're right you're absolutely
you're absolutely right but you know
what it's okay my kids are well taken
care of and it's just me living in this
house so I'm happy to move on I've got a
deal in me to work and to develop my
career and I'd like to probably buy
something like a double where I could
get that set income on the side I
wouldn't want to rent her next door
today that might be your next that might
be your next move but but right now
let's just get your career going if you
have a steady stream of income because
you've raised your competency in the
real estate business and you're actually
making some bucks doing that you're
gonna have the money to buy some other
rentals and even pay cash and move up in
house later if you want to you're gonna
have money to do all that if you'll just
stay super conservative like we're
talking about you got no personal
overhead no payments your life is in a
really really good position